how much do you pay attention to
approval ratings
well not anymore
i'm joking i was paying attention in the
mid 60s
president biden claims he doesn't care
about his approval ratings but the next
poll might make him pay attention his
approval rating has now fallen below his
deeply unpopular vice president kamala
harris for the first time since their
time in office the president clocking in
at 43 percent tahrir says 44
the sad state of affairs for the white
house is a major boon for the gop with
republicans becoming increasingly
bullish on the prospect of a red wave in
next year's midterms you know rachel i
want to come to you first on this do you
think it's inflation or maybe the crisis
at the border or maybe just the
inability to set an agenda and pass it
that americans can get behind why why
are americans so down on president biden
and kamala harris for that matter
well first of all i just want to comment
on jimmy fallon how nice he is to joe
biden remember he had to apologize for
humanizing donald trump when he had him
on it's so interesting um look he is
wildly unpopular i think the first thing
that happened that really made people
stand up and go no more was what
happened in afghanistan i brought that
up in the last segment because i think
it was just so emblematic but there is
nothing that has gone right for me
personally i think the biggest issue is
the loss of freedom that we've
experienced over the last couple of
years
it's this normalization of the
government taking control of our lives
whether it's when and if we can go to
church um when we can open our
businesses if our kids can go to school
this is outrageous and frankly um look i
think there's going to be a huge wave
for for republicans there's no doubt in
my mind the question is do they deserve
it and what will they do with that power
because with just a few exceptions rand
paul um senator ron johnson who's been a
hero in the senate
jim jordan i don't hear republicans
talking enough about our loss of freedom
about the the road that we're on i
believe on to a chinese
communist chinese credit score system um
all of these things that are happening
that are so scary and so non
un-american um these are the things i
want to hear republicans talk about for
them to deserve our vote of course i'd
vote for them over what i see here which
is absolute failure on the part of the
the democrats i don't see one thing that
biden's doing right but i would like to
see more from republicans in terms of
speaking up for the liberties that we've
lost over the last two years
that's powerful and it's absolutely
right we should be able to sit here and
say man i'm excited about what this
politician brings to the table instead
of holding our nose and voting for
whoever you know hasn't made our life
worse today tyrus i remember in 2019
sitting there going you know only donald
trump could lose this next election for
donald trump then we got hit with a
virus and things kind of changed and i
think the virus was a big part of why he
lost the election in 2020.
can republicans
you know what can they do to prevent
themselves from hitting this red wave
because the map sure looks good for them
well i mean first of all yeah i don't it
doesn't matter who was president during
a pandemic you're not going to see that
through even though i i thought
president trump did an outstanding job
in terms of getting
the vaccinations going and getting
people an opportunity to get better
faster and his focus was always on
getting america back to work people
heard that they got behind that and they
believed in that this administration you
know they all their entire thing was to
undo everything he did the only thing i
would tell him you want to undo maybe
just don't like undo a like on one of
his tweets because his deeds the deeds
ladies and gentlemen of the jury the
deeds outweigh the tweets and now we're
seeing no deeds and no tweets so we
can't even get entertained while we're
being treated miserably here's the thing
though to be fair to be fair
president joe is more like neck and neck
with vp you know what i'm saying it's
like within an area of one or two points
i can tell you right here's some here's
something free you want to get 10 points
right now 10 points right now on those
polls simple all you got to do is go to
the cam when you're on vacation sit up
at the beach and be like hey
previous administration
whoever was in charge was running since
we got rid of you guys we're going to
bring you back we want to pick your
brain about the border bring back some
of your old some of the things that you
were doing right and we're going to get
it right we are bad we're going to stick
with that we got the border lock down
that in itself is accountability knowing
what's right and you're going to get
some points back for that try that
deeds get some deeds done i think they
would love to get 10 points in any way
they can right now dr sapphire we just
talked about how president biden kamala
harris probably were elected based on
this premise that they'll bring some
sort of resolution to coronavirus here
we are a year into it we know exactly
where we sit we're in boxes we're not
sitting at a table in new york city
right now has has president biden done
anything to validate that narrative from
the 2020 election in this last year
well joey the reason that he is now
below i guess tyrus he's neck and neck
but he is technically below vp harris
and that is because uh the way that he's
handled the pandemic and in that it has
been he completely has politicized the
virus he blamed the unvaccinated for
spreading it now that democrats are
actually getting breakthrough infections
you even have washington post saying no
no we shouldn't be shaming people for
getting coveted well we shouldn't have
been shaming anybody all along they
catered to the teachers unions that kept
children out of school they've
completely flubbed the booster rollout
which caused two high-level fda
administrators to actually leave and now
that we have omicron here that we have
the high amount of immunity in the
population a milder variant and now is
the time that we should say hey it's
time to move forward but fauci and biden
just can't get out of the way the best
thing that they could do coming into the
midterms is to remove these federal
mandates because as we know we have
coveted circulating in the vaccinated
the unvaccinated and even the boosted
the re the message needs to be do what
you can to protect yourselves protect
your families but we're going to get out
of the way we're going to remove that
osha mandate we're going to pull back on
a lot of these lawsuits and let states
take for take accountability for their
people and get people back to work
because these mandates cause the worker
shortages which is what is causing this
complete spiral out of control right now
you know richard build back better bbb
is doa inflation is no longer transitory
and governor abbott's building us a wall
down there what can democrats do to to
get some momentum on their side or just
to tweak americans interest in possibly
voting for one of them here in just
about a year and a half
i think that's a great question and i
agree with tyrus
the idea that you have to have some
deeds here but let's be very clear if
you voted for donald trump in the last
election you're not going to vote for
joe biden for his re-election so nobody
should have talked to those voters and
instead should focus on the 78 million
people that got him to the white house
and that means he has to continue to
deliver on the promises he made to those
voters he made a promise to fix student
loan debt in this country he made a
promise to ensure and secure voting
rights for african-americans and people
of color all across this country he made
a promise that he was going to have a
conversation with the base that got him
to the game which were african-american
voters and now more than ever the
president needs to talk to his base if
he's talking to his base he will have a
good midterms if he stops talking to his
base he won't and i thought what was
very interesting in this poll was this
every elected leader in washington was
negative outside of john roberts the
chief justice supreme court who's not
elected and appointed and he runs away
from politics as fast as he can
well maybe you should talk to joe
mentioned if he wants to know where
americans are is based or not hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else